when you have men spending a bunch of
money on women when you have I I
honestly I've thought about this and I'm
playing around with this idea but you
guys can tell me what you think I think
that women should spend money on men yes
yes okay hear me out hear me out I think
women are in their true femininity it's
not really about money it's not really
about soft life if you look back I want
you guys to Google a day in the life of
the Amish these women get up at like
6:00 a.m. to milk the cows they tow the
fields they help their husbands like
true femininity is not it's not the soft
Life wearing a pretty dress no true
femininity is serving the men yes yes
guys